i want you to take me back to obviously
you're part of
my favorite album ever illmatic which is
probably
if you were to you know interview a
hundred
taste makers in hip-hop it'd probably
get the most first place votes
you know what i'm saying i think it's
probably undisputedly
that's a mount rushmore album yes um
when did you first meet nas 1990
or 91 when i was hanging around with
large professors in
queens shout out to large professor now
that was this
this was uh was this around the time
live at the barbecue at release or was
it before that
it was it was around it's around that
time
and and yep before that
and when you're working on illmatic when
you're working on on
with nas are you like aware at the
moment because i feel like
so much we're living in the moment so
sometimes we don't realize like the
history we're a part of or
or like like were you like aware at the
time are you conscious of like yo this
[ __ ] is like
this is going to change hip hop well
depending
on who got the beat and anytime i'm
working with him
you know something good is going to
happen
so that's basically what that was and
when i
when he heard the beat that it triggered
something in him and you know
he on the spot he came up with the hook
and he was like yo i want you to
i want you to say this hook i want you
to sing this hook you know
did it i ain't going to do it at first
but i did it i ended up doing it
yeah it's crazy because i also feel like
you don't get a you don't get enough you
don't get props as much as you should
as a also as a as an artist
i mean as a producer you know you i just
feel like
as an artist as well i feel like you
don't get the
uh the respect maybe am i supposed to be
getting all this
respect and stuff from like i don't know
i don't care bro yeah okay because you
know what people
are gonna be who they are it's all good
man you know you you got people out here
who are clueless
on what pete rock has done you know how
important he is
all that you know what i'm saying and
then you got people that
show love you got people that's like yo
you
or that [ __ ] still you know what i'm
saying and um
hey man you know it is what it is you
know what i'm saying i'm not
i'm not mad at nobody you know there's
so many dope people that
producers rappers that i i want to work
with still
um yeah i would love to hear the for the
freddie gibbs for me would be
would be would be special
and listen i will put my foot in that
one and the end of a
ghost face a ghost face project would be
[ __ ] insane
too that that put two feet in that